there are five worlds that you explore
in Demon Souls
there's boletaria castle the stone bank
tunnels the Tower of Lotteria the valley
of defilement and the shrine of storms
five worlds and five arch stones to take
you there but there's a sixth arch stone
and a sixth world beyond lies the
northern limit and while it was cut
pretty early on in development remnants
of this world and its law remain if you
want to go in the running to win two
thousand US dollars then I challenge you
to design the world that lies beyond
this arch stone skip to the end of the
video to learn more but stay tuned to
learn everything that we know about this
place and for that we're gonna have to
hack the game and travel inside the arch
stone itself here we go
welcome to the northern limit according
to an early description of this area we
were meant to explore a hinterland of
icy mountains here and because it was a
land entrusted with an arch stone it was
one of the six locations that the
monumentals used to help mend the fabric
of reality after the rise of the old one
land still remained
we entrusted six elders with six
precious art stones one the king of a
small yet diligent land one - the king
of the borrower's underground one to the
wise queen of the great ivory tower one
to the chieftain of lost and nil for
tuned souls one to the Shaymin of The
Tempest worshiping shadowmen and the
last the great Giants of the northern
lands that last line is unique amongst
the others in that the arch stone wasn't
granted to a ruler of the Giants unlike
in the human lands so perhaps their
society was more communal rather than
hierarchical regardless with all of the
six art stones intact thus followed
another period of peace however man's
memory of history is our short and
before long she repeated his mistakes
the monumentals perished and the arch
stones long forgotten and the
short-sighted king allant
once again aroused the old one I'd like
to make the case that the sixth arch
stone might have been the catalyst for
the fall of the monumentals and the rise
of the old one it's the only art stone
that's broken after all and the land
beyond it has a lot to do with the
rediscovery of soul arts
special thanks to Loki who is becoming a
regular feature on this channel because
he discovered crucial information that
was hidden on the Japanese demon swords
website from 2009 the prologue for demon
souls here reads the king of the
northern country boletaria a lot
discovered a giant linchpin temple in a
hinterland of icy mountains at the
limits of human inhabited land and
acquired soul arts this description of a
hinterland of icy mountains at the edge
of human civilization it lines up with
the northern limit that you're seeing on
screen and as for the lynchpin temple
this is said to be where King allant
discovered the sole arts and it's likely
he did this with the help of Lord Rydia
radial is an MPC that you find locked in
a Cell he has the soul of a legendary
hero and he carries the moniker little a
lot which makes it very likely that he's
directly related to the king but most
importantly Riddhi L can be connected
with the sixth arch stone the northern
limit of the sixth arch stone is
described as a hinterland and is said to
be at the limits of human inhabited land
just so radial is called
a frontier Lord in a Japanese item
description and being a lord at the edge
of civilization would logically put him
in close proximity to something that's
called the northern limit for him to be
stationed here implies that there's a
certain hostility between these two
lands and indeed there actually are a
few items that reference such a conflict
long ago the arch stone of the northern
limit was given to the great Giants of
the northern lands in such Giants are
mentioned in two weapons first they're
mentioned in brand which is an enormous
hammer
that's wielded by garl Vinland and it's
treasure of the Vinland family
it has distortion on one side and this
is said to be proof that it was wielded
by an old giant killer second conflict
with the Giants is mentioned in Makoto a
katana that's named after a giant of a
distant country and is likely crafted
with the soul of such a being one way or
another it was in this land of the
Giants that king allant
threw radial discovered the sole arts
within a temple actually it's very
likely that the temple they discovered
here was the Nexus since the Nexus is a
temple it houses the monumentals who
banned the sole arts and it houses the
old one who energizes such arts we know
that it was a Lunt who roused the old
one
the description of radials weapon reads
one of Lord radials most storied
exploits is his theft of this weapon
from the witch in the sky so this weapon
is almost certainly referencing the
maiden in black first note that the
weapon is a long rod and it has a light
at the end second note that this same
sort of staff is favored by the maiden
in black and lastly note that the maiden
in black could easily be characterized
as the witch in the sky especially since
this ending cutscene has us fall all the
way down to land from the nexus with all
of this evidence taken together it's
pretty clear that Lord radio Lord of the
frontier discovered the Nexus or at
least a way to access it in the lands
that bordered his own here whether it
was through or fair subterfuge or just
word of mouth a land rediscovered the
soul arts and brought unprecedented
prosperity to the Northern Kingdom of
boletaria that is until a lance lust for
power awakened the old one and a
colorless deep fog began to sweep across
the land demons began to roam mankind
faces extinction and the mistakes of the
past began to play out again if you're
an artist
interested in depicting the world of the
sixth arch stone or you're just someone
with a great idea who wants to
Commission an artist for this
competition this part is for you the
prize pool includes two thousand US
dollars and a video feature split
between the top ten finalists and unlike
in previous art competitions this time
you can depict anything you like as long
as it's related to the world of the
sixth arch stone or just related to what
we discussed in this video so play to
your strengths whether that's landscapes
enemies bosses NPCs weapons or maybe a
combination of those things this time I
just want you to put your best foot
forward as always you can do that by
listening very carefully to the content
in this video and then thinking really
critically about your concept before you
start drawing to get you started let's
recap and let's cover some concepts I
would consider if I were in your shoes
if you're drawing a landscape I would
the northern limit appears to be in a
snowy mountainous region bear in mind
that a lot of people will decide to
depict it this way so your world
building skills will be required to make
this place feel unique perhaps you'd
also like to consider depicting the
human frontier on the edge of this place
as the northern limit is meant to be on
the precipice of human civilization as a
result I imagine a lot of fear and
mystery about what lies beyond just so
the cut enemies that were supposed to be
featured in the land of the Giants
they're clearly designed to be really
outlandish I didn't mention them in the
video but just look at some of them
they're very strange you can read more
about them in links in the description
but generally I think there is a lot you
can do with the cut content whether
that's building upon these existing
enemies or maybe you want to design your
own ideas just using the outlandish
theme that they have earlier in this
video i theorize Don bullet arias
conflict with this land so don't be
afraid to tackle important historical
events in your drawings as well things
like the conflict between early
boletaria
and the land beyond or radials raid on
the nexus or the concept of al aunt
waging full-on war with the Giants there
are no Giants featured in the cut
content so and the closest we get to
seeing one is probably the one that's on
the broken arch stone here we see what
we assume is a giant towering over small
inhuman warriors so perhaps the Giants
were just the leading tribe in a
confederacy of outlandish beings that
live away from human civilization this
is the sort of speculation that makes
for really great world buildings so try
your hand at it as well oh and in the
description I'll link some good Let's
Plays as well so you can watch a
playthrough of this game even if you
haven't played it I recommend including
a written portion with your entry
answering questions like the ones I'm
gonna write on screen these will help to
flesh out your entry and they'll help to
build out your world whether you
contribute a landscape an enemy a boss
or an event or none of these things or
the combination of these things I'm so
excited
what you guys cook up once you have a
concept to be sure to compare it with
entries that have won in previous
competitions because that will give you
a good idea of the sort of criteria that
we're looking to meet finally the due
date for your submission is mid-august
so on the 15th at midnight Pacific
Standard Time convert your image or
images into an attachable jpg or PNG and
submit them to Archstone challenge at
gmail.com if you must use cloud services
just make sure you have the permissions
set correctly please also include the
name you'd like to go by your paypal
address and a link to your portfolio if
you have one all of these things are
there for the event that you do end up
winning if you have additional questions
just join the discord link in the
description and check out our FAQ and
our art chat where moderators will
answer your questions in real time I'd
also like to give one last disclaimer
this time when you enter the art
competition you are automatically giving
permission for me to potentially include
your art in an art book I am endeavoring
to make so if your work is chosen to be
included you will definitely be
contacted your name and social media
will definitely be prominently displayed
next to your entry and you will also
receive a free copy of the book I found
a publisher that I think can do this
whole thing justice and I'm working on
it the whole point is to create
something that can better display all of
these entries because there are so many
entries I want to talk about that don't
lie within the top ten and a book is the
perfect medium to show off all of your
work thank you for your contributions to
this community art competitions bring
myself and everyone who watches them a
lot of joy and I can't wait to see what
you create see you in August